in august of 2015 at a press conference
in berlin
german chancellor angela merkel said
something so standard for a politician
it was almost easy to miss a feeling
there shaftened us we can do it or
perhaps more accurately
we will manage it the it to be managed
referred to the unprecedented number of
people seeking refuge in europe that
summer
and in germany especially we are now
waiting to
give our papers after them i wish
i would go to the germany by late august
germany was already expecting a record
800 000
asylum seekers and between 2015 and 2016
over 1.2 million would apply
it's been five years since merkel made
the virschafen dust claim
but did she manage it
central to this question is an
understanding of integration
and we're going to use the government's
own definition to measure merkel's
progress
there are three basic tenets equality of
opportunity
the actual participation in all areas of
social cultural and economic life
and a reciprocal process involving the
receptiveness of the majority
we're going to examine how these three
hallmarks of integration stack up
against reality
but first let's be clear about who these
asylum seekers
are
75 of adult males and 65
of adult female refugees were under 35
compared with 28 and 25 percent in
germany
they're mostly men outnumbering refugee
women three to one
and they're also far more likely to
suffer from psychological trauma
which can make it more challenging to
find and retain
work
the good news is that the rate of paid
work among refugees since their arrival
goes up pretty dramatically within the
first five years
but they still earn on average 55 of
what a german does
now refugees do not necessarily lack
education or experience
in fact the share of refugees and
certain occupations before they'd
emigrated
was not all that different from germans
but after they'd emigrated
they were far more likely to work as a
trainee or an assistant
with a noticeable drop in those
specialized fields requiring a master's
degree or higher
now the plan for us for my family is
studying
and finish the german course and then
for me start my first step in profession
in germany because
the pharmacist in syria or in egypt i
was
in egypt also different from the system
here
and navigating the german system
successfully
requires german
[Music]
of the refugees that came between 2013
and 2016
only around 10 percent could speak
german however by the time they arrived
the federal government already had
integration courses in place to aid
their transition
what we had now today the german culture
about the christmas and traditionals
it's so cool over 2.3 million people
have been admitted to integration
courses since they were first introduced
in 2005.
but even after all this time many
experts say there's no consensus
on how effective these courses are in
finding jobs
housing german partners and german
friends
uh
um
the most far right-wing nationalist
party in germany the alternative for
deutschland or afd
was founded pretty recently in 2013.
its platform then was euroskeptic
but angela merkel's welcoming policy
toward refugees
literally her verschaffendas remark
galvanized a very new political party
and its base their platform quickly
became vehemently anti-refugees
foreign
and nowhere was the jump in the afd's
popularity more apparent in subsequent
elections
than in the former communist east german
states
but negative views of asylum seekers
aren't just a regional phenomenon
nationally they're even slightly worse
today
so did merkel manage the refugee influx
by the government's own standards
not exactly there's been some progress
on jobs and integration
but refugees still fall behind on some
key benchmarks
like employment rates and wages
and reciprocal acceptance in germany
comes with no guarantees
but so far we've looked at the situation
for refugees within germany
what about outside the numbers of asylum
applications continue to drop well below
pre-2015 and 2016 levels
and the percentage of those actually
granted asylum
is also on the decline
[Music]
one way miracle owner government has
managed those numbers is by preventing
refugees
from reaching germany in the first place
they've strengthened frontex the
european border and coast guard agency
and they've played a key role in
negotiating treaties to severely limit
refugees passage
including a controversial one with
turkey in 2016.
[Music]
for a hefty price tag of up to 6 billion
euros
turkey became the tourniquet for
quote-unquote irregular
migration into europe at the very center
of the integration question
is of course a question of identity like
many countries and it's not just in the
eu
germany continues to grapple with how to
define itself
whether it's a country of immigration
like the us
or not as chancellor merkel encouraged
germans to embrace that identity
and many did how will that change once
miracle's popular leadership has ended
only time will tell